[Music]
oh we know that camera angle I have an
update on Dayton and this is [ __ ]
fresh and by the way we have two sources
now
um I love it
so here's what the title of the video is
I need a place to stay a few days away
from transphobe fam who decided to have
a weekend reunion now before I play this
there's new information from his
Facebook that must be shared you know
how his younger brother's there and his
youngest brother's been visiting his
younger brother left now his younger
brother is coming back
do you want to know why
his dad has cancer
oh gee any wait a minute and he's he
hasn't even no once thought to mention
that no his dad has cancer and that's
why his brother is coming back his dad's
old you know and it's the kind that you
don't get better from and it's the
[ __ ] The Watchman yeah you know the
kind you get better from yeah it's not
that that's not the case
he is doing
this my sister my younger brother her
husband they're all around the house
with my dad said I'm so I can hear my
dad talking on the phone downstairs
they're all around the house
his younger brother's back in town
because your dad has cancer
every one of these bigots
have done something belligerent towards
me about the skinhead beating me
yeah you know what's belligerent cancer
yeah
the years all of them participated in
some sort of violent behavior and most
of them were doing something physically
violent physically violent to me
as a means of bullying and intimidating
me your father has cancer
yeah your dad's dying now talking about
the skinhead beating the [ __ ] out of you
what's gonna happen when they're all
dead and he's just alone in that house
still talking about all of them
I don't know
because that's the that's the end game
here he's going to outlive them all and
he's just gonna be in that house
squatting in an abandoned house with no
power
making these videos no I hope I hope
that has power but has faulty wiring
Spanish seven goddamn years I am
recording this right now because they
are all just hanging out together
downstairs that's horrible I can't
believe it that's disgusting that your
family is all joining together to Rally
around their fathers dying
Security in their minds that they
fur have some sort of remorse for that
they do not he is ramping up again I
think they outright avoid me I believe
that they essentially are shunning I
believe that they don't avoid no but I
don't know I think you're wrong they
don't avoid you you you film yourself
avoiding that you avoid them you sit in
your you sit in your little dust bin
that you call your room and [ __ ] and
and record yourself about how your how
much your family hates you by the way
using a brand new iPhone that they
bought you I I get that he is avoiding
them I'm just saying they don't really
they probably just also don't often seek
I think they probably gave up they
probably just gave up yeah they're like
just let them go let them sulk let him
go upstairs
because of things that they did wrong
and I'm keeping this on record my cat
just came in a room right here so
do you hate the cat too did he let the
white supremacist beat you are you also
mad at the cat I don't know are we mad
at the cat do we hate the cat
[ __ ] you angry I'm sure they could
overhear me out from downstairs no they
can't
no they can't because I'm angry I can
barely hear you sir and I got I got this
[ __ ] cranked it was [ __ ]
I don't know what to do because
I have an idea
leave yeah just leave get a goddamn job
Al yeah Beat It
infuriating I mean today I spent
an hour I'm sure probably longer I don't
know like an hour of
posting status on Facebook one steps
after another after another just venting
and like you know all and that's by the
way how I know all this information oh
like big letters on you know just
[ __ ]
spewing you know all these emotions like
just like it's so angry because I woke
up hearing them downstairs oh I'm having
a good old time you know they're all
enjoying themselves and they're ignoring
so you woke up
to the to the sounds of a delightful
family get-together yes
[Music]
and yeah
isn't that something like you've come to
appreciate especially when you get older
like when you don't see your family as
much yeah when you like go visit for
Christmas or whatever and you get up and
you can smell coffee and there's like a
bunch of people talking and you're like
ah you know it's kind of nice yeah isn't
that the normal shouldn't that be your
normal first yeah how nice yeah but you
you don't understand what it's like to
beat up by a skinhead and you're in this
house
he's been dead for two years not his
ghost bearings do all that [ __ ] that's
crazy and I'm so [ __ ] infuriated at
this I mean I don't know I usually avoid
posting a lot of stuff all at once on
Facebook like as far as personal posts
oh my God I [ __ ] am done with this
[ __ ] man if only somebody listening you
get me screenshots of those posts
because I'm sure that [ __ ] makes a
person look unstable or something I
don't know and I'm not trying to look
unstable to my
yeah did so many people like constantly
just write real advice to him that he's
never gonna take in the chat oh I know
there's literally people just saying to
just just get a job cut your hair just
go for a walk chill yeah
friends on Facebook but oh my God that
is horrible that [ __ ] is horrible you do
not all gather together it's like
Halloween I'm like this is if if it's
anybody's a holiday right now it is my
holiday what you have wait you have a
holiday Halloween is holiday first of
all
you're an adult Man Halloween is
children's holidays yeah I mean I enjoy
Halloween a little bit
but let's calm down second of all you
don't get like a monopoly on it no like
like Royce doesn't get to go guys
Halloween's mine this year nobody else
is allowed to eat chocolate candy
nobody's allowed to enjoy the fall
because it's my season it's my season if
I even catch a whiffy you enjoying my
[ __ ] what do you think you're called
dibs on [ __ ] holidays I got Christmas
all that's left for you is Arbor Day and
Indigenous people day yeah
and you're not allowed to call it
Columbus
Day to celebrate Columbus Day you only
get to celebrate the indigenous people
day congratulations you're you're
welcome yeah don't say we never do
nothing for you and Frozen got all of it
all Asian New Year he got already so
that's his [ __ ]
eggs are enjoying Halloween my holiday
oh [ __ ]
wait I swear to God Virgie if I even if
I even get you I'd catch a whiff of you
thinking about taking your children
trick-or-treating yeah
skull in with a sledgehammer
so so Virgie what do you think about
getting Arbor Day as a vacation I you
know happy with it I like sap
yeah sure you do you imagine that though
is that street name for heroin Virgie I
don't know you people I don't know what
you call it
yo let me get some of that sap it's
[ __ ] true like five reasons why it
would be called
well it saps you have energy that's for
sure
it's nice and brown yeah oh that's true
look it's covered like Warren Sap
right you should be you know able to
focus on stuff that I'm trying to get
ready to dress up as you know go out as
uh to to parties this weekend I don't
know how the hell I'm gonna leave my
house downstairs of any of them
downstairs acting the way that they act
because
hello are you not paying attention do
you not see the plight of his people he
doesn't know how he's even gonna leave
his house because there's people in it
talking how's he going to get through
the people what is what is he gonna do
ask him politely to move to the side
Royce I don't think they're all just
like jammed up in the foyer of the house
okay so they're playing Red Rover like
with locked arms not letting them leave
what if they really are just doing [ __ ]
like this to them all the time and it's
really not funny oh my God we don't
believe him
they really are torturing them keeping
them in the house as soon as the camera
as soon as the camera is shut off the
beatings begin they stick [ __ ]
surround them with arms locked and
they're like nightmare nightmare
nightmare nightmare
oh cool thank you Sarah just said he
texted us he goes signed up for your
locals just now thanks bud real freely
thanks man really appreciate it I have a
good feeling about it I think it's going
to do well I think it's going to do good
to do good
[ __ ] it already is doing good dude I'm
watching the [ __ ] locals over there
it's not so many notifications for new
members I know it's pretty cool right
it's pretty cool well let me see if it
fix it because the camera's doing the
stupid good thing
um you know what I was thinking that
might help that might actually help him
um there's somebody else who's been in a
in a really rough spot and that
gentleman's name is Mike Lindell okay
and remember in Mike lindell's book
what are the odds from crack addict to
CEO
unbelievable now I want you to look at
this book cover you see his face that's
him now but he had a dark past there it
is
now dark past and for some reason him as
a child in the back
um so and apparently there's like 15
chapters just about Dominion voting
machines so honestly yeah no I'm not
going to say there's a lot of dominion
voting stuff but a lot of these are just
punch cards
uh I am uh Virgie I already saw that I
was gonna say
um somebody uh tipped over on locals
yeah yeah in the chat how does that work
they just it's like oh [ __ ] that's so
cool I just saw it uh Hunter for five
says do you think he bathes in his
flakes like a chin come on
[Laughter]
she's [ __ ] brilliant
and they're posting pictures of flower
yes oh
he pulls his blanket over his head and
does little Circle Center he just does
his little does a little Shake there's a
little shake
his psoriasis droppings have the same
consistency don't say psoriasis
droppings again
[Laughter]
is leaving his thank you that's what
they're called Dayton leavings
all right sorry Dayton you were saying
you could always know where he's walking
around the house because it's like
following a dry slug
laughs
[ __ ] looks like LeBron James when he
[ __ ] puts the powder on his hands
every time he goes somewhere
poof
turcation they do not give a [ __ ] you've
ever heard about her donut
it's like you know how to find him
because it's just like following like
it's like if you poked a hole in a bag
of flour
it's like one of those Looney Tunes
[ __ ] episodes where they've got the
trail of gunpowder behind them
Jesus Christ
[ __ ] Hansel and Gretel over here
about anything but their egos and it's
[ __ ] awful all the belligerent
Behavior I mean my sister and her
husband they are much larger people than
me they are my everyone's larger than
you you're the little twink the size of
football players I'm at [ __ ] 120
pound scrawny person next to them and
they felt the two of them shoved me
around right upstairs on right in the
hallway upstairs right outside my door
right here like that was like months ago
they shut me around and cussed me out
about the about talking about the
skinhead that was their means because
he's dead and they're because you're
insufferable and they're sick of you
talking about their [ __ ] dead brother
man
you piece you're lucky you're not you're
gonna they should be punching you more
you know you should be getting way more
you know what it probably was he was
probably ranting and [ __ ] raving
about his [ __ ] brother and screaming
and [ __ ] and they were like hey your
[ __ ] dad has cancer you're going to
[ __ ] depend him with distress shut
the [ __ ] up yeah exactly that's a really
good point finding a Nazi brother they
were making sure you didn't kill their
[ __ ] father and husband you people
that's how he is this is him this is
this is all he thinks of intimidating
and gaslighting a victim I recorded a
part of that behavior that's crazy those
people are [ __ ] they have not made
one attempt since that interaction since
that altercation of them being
physically violent to me in front of my
parents in this house in this house he
said a bingo card does anyone have one
single instance of a morseful behavior
since then they have been smugged the
entire time they've been ever I need
minimum wage and I have a Bingo but he
haven't heard it yet anytime never been
in this house since since that incidence
since that incident occurred they have
come over the house being smug is hell
ignoring it knowing that they're
ignoring them I believe it's pronounced
smudge you know [ __ ] terrible
situation I mean you can hear right now
the small children downstairs having fun
yeah let's play about it playing and
having a good time can you
believe it and stuff I mean their kids
are having like temper tantrums
downstairs they're not that they don't
like they're kids that was beating me I
mean my sister is Raising her this is
how this is how I feel when I was like
dealing with those neighbors it just
like kicked their cat out and they were
like hey he was just being really bad
and I'm like what was he doing and
they're like you know he was like he ate
a hole through the food bag and he was
jumping up on things and scratching
things on again I'm like so he was like
being a cat did you not foresee any of
these things when you gotta wait there's
a cat your cat was cat-like yeah it's
like the same thing but with kid these
kids are running around stuff but on the
floors yelling throwing temper tantrums
yeah they're [ __ ] kids
it's ironic because you know her
husband's black and you know allowed a
skinhead to beat that violent to a trans
person of less than half the size that's
[ __ ] crazy I mean if they could
overhear me right now I'm not [ __ ]
surprised I'm angry this is infuriated
he has these imaginary fights like all
the time dude you know uh rhinestone
hangnail two dollars Dayton Stimpy
powdered skin Dayton Stimpy powdered
skin man instead of powdered Toast Man
powdered skin man
that was a gross one okay that was a
good that was a gross one should not be
having this kind of time right now you
know
experiencing all this [ __ ] I mean I
experienced it a month ago when they
were here that was bad enough you don't
do this [ __ ] when a person is trying to
enjoy themselves during the holiday you
know you know whatever the one holiday
of the year that might Embrace trans
people
it's [ __ ] what these people are smug
bigots irresponsible [ __ ] okay yeah
they're irresponsible yes angry can you
imagine if one if you're giving off them
like a tick you imagine I would love
this video and for one of them to walk
through the door and I'm completely
panic and fall to the floor and start
crying I mean right now a lot so I am
recording it and it's venting about this
[ __ ] I need a place to [ __ ] say
anything
Dayton we wear masks on Halloween so
that so that we can get candy and
alcohol
it's it's not to hide our pain yeah by
the way says the guy who works good
point Dayton the guy who literally wears
dresses and hides behind makeup
because this is gonna be bad if I go
outside this room and interact with him
at all I mean thank God they don't
outright like you know interact with me
on their own they say generally away
from me but right now I am so they're
not even bothering you it's what you're
saying oh [ __ ] let me get this straight
you're admitting they're not even
bugging you I'm a good a good enough
mood to just be so even worse he's
admitting that generally they don't
bother him ever yeah
starving because I can't leave by the
way by the way the poster on the wall is
of one of Nicole Richie the room here I
do not want Christina no it's Nicole
Richie I think you're thinking of Nicole
Richie I know I messed up you're right I
apologize can I can I apologize like Jim
Cramer
yeah I'm sorry my hubris I don't know
what I was thinking
anytime that they're around
so I just live on like less than a meal
throughout the day that they're here
it's [ __ ] crazy that [ __ ] is so
archaic [ __ ] behavioral mentalities
it's so sickening do you like archaic
fire they're a good band right yeah
they're pretty good yeah driving
[Laughter]
supporters and the ones that aren't
Trump supporters are pretending to be
progressives they are not liberals they
are allowing bad things to happen to a
trans person or they ignore the emotions
of the trans person the emotional state
of that person who has been through all
that trauma and you know all that awful
behavior all of that violence all that
disgusting [ __ ] that happened to me
because they don't want to have
responsibility for what they consider
you know the situation they'll scapegoat
by saying you're an adult you're your
own person it's like [ __ ] you okay [ __ ]
I just look back at the video that's
super creepy me walking behind you I'm
sorry
that I had to look it would look like oh
I mean look I just like I stuck up
behind you for no reason it was very odd
this is weird as [ __ ] too because then
like he's pulling the Jake's menu [ __ ]
out and Louie comes up and I thought he
was at your house because you walked
behind him I was like what the [ __ ] was
he talking to Louie what if I I was
really there I'm surprised [ __ ]
you know we are missing out on some
serious opportunities for bits here yeah
[ __ ] seriously it's so [ __ ] funny
sorry sorry I just saw it again
hey Jesus Christ
sorry effort letting that happen in your
family [ __ ] you forever and then
claiming Christianity or you know on one
side of the family and the other side of
family claiming liberalism on any level
there is nothing Christian about it and
there's nothing liberal about it oh
again with the [ __ ] religion thing
again both of those are [ __ ] horrible
things to hide behind and what's worse
is I feel like if I even go down there
and interact at all my sisters is going
to hide behind her children because
she's such a coward about everything
that she does wrong
absolutely awful I mean I needed a place
to stay because I do not want to be
dealing with this [ __ ] this weekend I
need a place to be away from these
people it sucks because I don't want to
be away from my cat because that's the
only comfort in my life right now is my
cat Amen brother yeah
I mean I do not even want to even be
around this place so I'm just gonna have
to go and leave my cat here it's awful
I need a place to stay I need who would
have you because we've talked about this
the entire trans Community doesn't even
like you in your town remember they like
disowned him
wait he has a cat yeah well this it's
not his cat it's it's really his
family's cat I was about to say poor
[ __ ] thing probably looks like it
just came in from the snow every [ __ ]
day
he's constantly shaking let me stay I
think my younger brother's probably
going to be here until Monday I miss her
but my mom said yesterday over the phone
or whatever I heard her say something
about or no not over the phone she was
talking to my dad and she was saying
something about him uh his flight would
be Monday so I assumed that she meant
that he was flying into town that I know
he's here today I think that he's not
leaving until Monday okay that's fine I
don't really need to know all his
itinerary yeah but he doesn't know how
to talk any other way you know what I
mean
I don't know he might be coming today I
don't know maybe before it might be two
o'clock yeah it depends if the flight's
delayed I don't know I mean and we look
up the rest of this video is just from
looking at flight tracker
Jesus [ __ ] Christ bro relax
anyway I mean we don't have to play
anymore that's pretty much the gist of
it um she's doing all right though yeah